how's it going bros my name is Peter
pound let's find Lilly finish this [ __ ]
let's finish this [ __ ] let's do it oh
this is the end let's do this
yeah oh god there's so many die die you
scumbags
I owe a change that you guys [ __ ]
want some [ __ ] you want some of it I
wait wait when they watch them what oh
that sneaky [ __ ] what's down there
that's right [ __ ] it's gonna sort of
try and get him cut no no aah fine I
guess
burning hell that's it I hate how they
breathe like dark disgusting this time
you're not dogs
you're Devils from hell all right now
I'm gonna go this way
nevermind I'm gonna go this way ha ha no
I have to go down here oh I'm preparing
to shoot oh my god oh god I hate these
yes see that I just come on potatoes one
potato two potato three potato four
banana yeah that's four potatoes
thank you everyone thank you for that
was four potatoes that count it okay
well let's go further down this way if
this bike seems like a dead end to me oh
my god Let Go me you're trash you're all
trash you're all trash you're old shitty
[ __ ] [ __ ] I hate you
you'll smell like [ __ ] give me back my
dog gave me back Snoop Dog eh eh eh eh
eh what [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] off
you want some I'm not going to let you
escape the screen that said you're all
gonna die
and what else and we'll [ __ ] else oh
that's right y'all gonna die you're all
gonna pay oh my god what the [ __ ] is
that
oh god he's gonna shoot
hey and I'm dead that's cool alright
wait for it and a double jump and I'm
dead you're all gonna die
get off me you spilt your trash your old
fresh trash trash your old trash oh god
you're all trash up up up up them to go
oh my god there's so many
oh my god there's so many No oh my god I
got even this is so intense
how is this even a video game don't try
and sneak up it oh my god oh my god
shoot the potato chip a potato chip
inseminate a cow damn it a and shoot the
potato my mom [ __ ] me
yes potato burning help potatoes burning
real potatoes potato oh the final piece
yay we did it
wait who he's into bondage to this guy's
my like my dream girlfriend oh don't
make stuff commander the nose Oh for
[ __ ] sake George your things I love
him
go man go
Geronimo you know it's the 90s when you
[ __ ] say Geronimo
oh they keeps going I was it hasta
LaVista - hey [ __ ] [ __ ] why not I'll
start a hasta la vista hasta isn't they
where he's dog when
the dark guy is the math teacher I'm
calling it right now are you ready
I guess
Oh
what's the
who we get a little loading there that's
nice
that's nice and neat well what the [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] creepy what the [ __ ] is
going on here I can slap I can now slap
get away get away
shoosh gonna go this swing hey guys [ __ ]
off slap you I'll slap you I'll slap you
you think I'm scared I can't go anywhere
hey guys I ain't scared of no ghosts
actually I guess I guess I am okay what
do I do here
this is super creepy mudding playing
this is a kid I've spoken [ __ ] myself
got him no how long do I gotta keep
doing this [ __ ] darkness
I could do this all day son damn it you
fight me you face the consequences
Oh God it really is dark did we overcome
our fear of Darkness oh my god you
almost hit your dog dude yourself it's
late come on boys
what we're back what happened not it's a
nice pajama oh boy
I want that pajama please oh man oh my
god what a [ __ ] awesome guy
darkness again
why [ __ ] please all right you've been
[ __ ] soiling yourself this whole game
did he fart oh he's not scared of the
dark anymore well you should be
is that Jar Jar what the [ __ ] Jar Jar
that's my spaceship you call it junk who
don't take a selfie I did it
beagle face what the [ __ ] is he doing to
him I don't know what's gonna happen
this is so weird
it did have an epic soundtrack I gotta
say like actually when we like a movie
soundtrack
okay we did it
holy [ __ ] no okay nevermind please
squish the [ __ ] out of him thank you
we did it holy [ __ ] I didn't think I
would actually pull through my God may
have used a few save states but that's
all part of them
yeah damn this game is hard man I cannot
like picture this as a kid playing this
game although I got I gotta say like
I've never heard of this game before and
it's such an awesome game I really
understand why why it was recommended to
me it really stands the test of time
obviously the animation and like the 3d
rendering is not what we're used to but
it's still [ __ ] cool and the gameplay
remind me a lot about limbo and they we
need more games like this this is fun I
also enjoyed kind of going back and
revisiting and relearning out of [ __ ]
play an old game kiss it's [ __ ]
different and a lot of it is better a
lot of it they do better I would say so
it's interesting how things have changed
um really though thank you so much for
watching this playthrough with me I had
a lot of fun and I hope you enjoyed it
as well hope we can do more in the
future so and you bros watching this
support set so thank you and if you want
to leave a like I really appreciate it
and I'm gonna go and have sex with that
pink cat really want to see more games
like this I know it odd world Jam or
whatever is that what it's called I know
that game is similar I never had a what
came was his out on PlayStation
PlayStation 1 I never had it I had a 64
and then I had an Xbox so anything any
game that came out or not any other
platform I'm I'm usually not familiar
with which is a shame cuz there's so
many great places a game more thanks
where's my thanks huh god damn this game
was harsh
it's coming a game I would love to
replay just because now that I actually
know how to play it I feel like I could
actually enjoy it more than being so
[ __ ] frustrated 1998 there you go
1998 holy [ __ ] that's like almost 10
years ago
not really um that's crazy
time flies put on your glasses and
confirm what the [ __ ] is this holy [ __ ]
this game was pushing boundaries look at
that [ __ ]
so remember when the teacher put us in
the closet and was like you're not
scared of the doc I thought for sure we
would wake up in the closet look all the
classmates are there yeah I remember all
of them the the Asian guy and the
african-american guy and oh and Jar Jar
Binks of course let's not forget about
him
[ __ ] 3d we watching all the cutscenes
in three days I'm sure oh my god oh not
in my face disgusting alright we don't
need to watch that oh man alright well
that was hard of Darkness thank you so
much for watching really enjoyed it and
man what a blast to the past okay Bryce
that's it stay awesome
charges shocker breaker or even their
name oh my god let's use hope you held
on to your hose you reduce how much
damage you'll take